how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in dog I actually think that there
is a lot of profound possibilities in
self-expression through selfie for
instance and this kind of seemingly
narcissistic oftentimes excessive
narcissism of constantly recording
oneself at home at an arm's length but I
think the the point to some degree has
to do with the context and what kinds of
things these self expressions do and how
they do it in other words are they
actually in a conversation with others
are they moving something are they doing
something besides self self-promotion if
that's part of it or is it part of a
dialogue I don't think we know the
answer yet but in part this might be in
fact I'm not putting it down but I think
it's it may be worth thinking about the
fact that the generation of selfies is
very young it's largely teenaged
generation actually I remember as myself
as a teenager and I had I have a son who
was a teenager not so long ago just
about four or five years ago and and in
a way this obsession with
self-expression the way we are promoting
it the way we democratize actually
vanity related to self-promotion
seems to me to be coming out of a as yet
fully developed brain function in some
ways and that is to me this concatenate
culture of the beautiful the thin the
young the the self the self that is
presented by the way self-promotion of
selfie perhaps
puts forward is is unlike what is the
real life on the ground for majority of
human beings on the planet Earth
I mean think of it university I just
your that critique is always right that
often we're talking about a certain kind
of privileged European citizens of
liberal democracies I think that's
absolutely right but there are people
with mobile phones very often and I
absolutely take that on board but I'm
always slightly reluctant at my critique
of young people going into their phone
because when I I teach young people and
when I show to work yeah I've got that's
why I'm saying I teach young people too
that they're using a technology that's
available to them and we had our own
technologies to perhaps not to the
visible in the same way we're using
these technologies to fashion themselves
and they're claiming ascent agency in
that and I don't begrudge them that but
I do want to pick you up on this idea
that Rembrandt was doing portraits
rather than engaging in kind of
narcissistic self explorations because
it seems to me is very interesting that
you chose a male artist and that we do
live in a culture where often we berate
young people and women particularly for
being overly anxious about their
appearance and self presentation and you
could have easily have talked about
Angelica Kauffmann right the one of the
women founders of the Royal Academy in
the eighteen in 1768 when it was founded
and Angelica Kauffmann painted no dozens
and dozens and dozens of self-portraits
and she did that she painted herself
with a paintbrush in hand with a canvas
in her lap and she did that because she
didn't have access to nude models she
wasn't allowed to draw in the same
classes as the men so you have to paint
yourself if you're not allowed access to
the same and the same way I think you
know when young women are tweeting I'm
really obsessed with a hashtag called
black girl magic lots of brilliant
beautiful black women are tweeting
pictures themselves or talking about
myself doing amazing things and if you
are a particular kind of subject that
has not been permitted a mode of
expression and articulation or if your
life is marginalized in a particular way
you might take that opportunity to
present yourself in a particular way and
I wouldn't ever be greater than that I
think
hey could I take up on this one because
I don't mean to dominate it between the
two of us no Steven have anything to
come in all those clothes I think you
should two points to make one is this is
not to say begrudging this young people
of women begrudging this to them the
point is there is an excess of it and an
excessive snart's ism which is not all
over the place but look we are we
constantly talk about this because it's
all in front of our eyes it's in our
news it's in our phones it's everywhere
my students are not that way I don't
look at them that way they're very young
as they enter they're 18 if that the
point about this is that this is not
solely about women and young people and
I agree with you women artists could
have been the case the use of Rembrandt
is very important because this is a man
who is self reflecting at a moment that
everyone is looking at the vanity of
things having things around them in
Holland of 17th century there are women
artists like let's go back before
Kalmykia such as Artemisia Gentileschi
who paints herself and and that's I
think it's unfair to say it's because
she didn't have a model I think it is a
self expression yeah of a very profound
consequence there well I think we're
never really gonna know quite what
Rembrandt was thinking when he was when
he was sitting there painting himselves
but I think the insights get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in aaaggghhh